If you're in the middle of the road, you don't have to worry about what your acquaintances
think of you.
I couldn't even do something like this
Skin contact is an important communication
Operation
Eh, now it's time to go in front of people like this People's Day It
's
okay, you should throw away the embarrassment of your trip
Ah ah ah
ame
I want to do everything I can and make it a trip without regrets
To be honest, I don't have any more money,
and
I'm desperately desperate
Sahato Minase I
do
n't mind, but let's go me  No, it's better to say that
two people's hands are soft
and high, and
holding hands means that
they just want to touch each other's skin, it's just an act for flirting.
And
wwoof with the three of us, including that sense of immorality,
I do it sometimes.